good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
it's funny how no one really covers the
big stories
instead the news media brings us minutia
all minutia
all the time card loads of it a
middle-aged professional golfer hurts
his leg in a car accident and the
networks go
wall to wall they gave his car crash
more coverage than they gave the bombing
of syria
literally then a few weeks later some
weird fake
duchess from la gives a boring interview
to oprah and we stopped the presses
it's all we talked about for days
meanwhile
something legitimately momentous happens
and it's crickets
just yesterday for example two sitting
members of the united states senate
announced that they oppose
the entire foundation of american civil
rights law
and then proceeded to attack the core
principle the main principle of our
country
some people on twitter were shocked by
it but otherwise you'd never really know
what happened
but it did happen tammy duckworth of
minnesota and maisie hirono of hawaii
publicly informed the white house that
until the biden administration
puts more people they like in powerful
jobs they will refuse to confirm
any white nominees quote i'm a no vote
on the floor on all
non-diversity nominees duckworth said
out loud with cameras rolling
i will vote for racial minorities and i
will vote for lgbtq
but anybody else i'm not voting for just
in case you missed it or unclear on the
meaning duckworth said this several
times and then maisie hirono backed her
up here's ronaldo yesterday on msnbc
tammy's position is
that until she gets a commitment from
the white house that there will be more
diversity representation in the cabinet
and senior white house
advisory positions she will not vote to
confirm
anyone who does not represent diversity
so this is not about pitting
one diversity group against another i
think this is a
well articulated focused position and i
am prepared to join her in that do you
think that by the administration has
been adequately receptive to your
entreaties for more diversity
obviously not otherwise tammy and i
wouldn't be taking our position
but we would like to encourage him to do
better
talk about stop the presses here you
have two
actual u.s senators announcing in public
they will deny
jobs to people who have the wrong skin
color that's not news
oh yes it is news though maisie hirono
and tammy duckworth may not realize its
news in their defense hirono and
duckworth are well known as the dimmest
politicians in washington
neither one could carry a dinner
conversation but not everyone
in congress is stupid or oblivious chuck
schumer certainly isn't the senate
majority leader misses nothing
chuck schumer has spent his entire life
telling us at high volume that racial
discrimination
is wrong which obviously it is then this
week two of his colleagues go on
television and demand
racial discrimination what did chuck
schumer think of that
chuck schumer didn't say a word about it
no one in the democratic party did
these are moral pygmies some of them
would sell their kids if the price was
right
some of them are actually race haters
probably and they may agree with it
but whatever their motives are the fact
that this happened
in public and no one in power said
anything about it as it did
seems like a turning point in our
country so to recap the most basic
principle we have
it's this all americans have an
inalienable right given by god
guaranteed by the constitution to be
judged solely and exclusively on the
basis of what they do of what they
choose
not on the basis of their race or their
genes
or who their parents were period
that is the entire promise of our
country it's why we're different
it's why people move here from other
countries it's why we're a
self-governing republic because
everyone is equal it's also by the way
in addition to everything else federal
law
it's written down what maisie toronto
and tammy duckworth did is not simply
morally repugnant
though once again it is morally
repugnant it's also illegal
title vi of the 1964 civil rights act
opens this way
quote no person in the united states
shall on the grounds of race color or
national origin
be excluded from participation in be
denied the benefits of or be subjected
to discrimination under any program or
activity receiving federal financial
assistance
end quote you cannot deny an american a
federal job
because of his race that is against the
law it has been against the law for
nearly 60 years
racial discrimination in government
hiring is a crime you may have heard
that before
it's on the wall of every break room in
every office in the united states in
fact the civil rights
act may be the most famous law that we
have
but then as now many prominent democrats
opposed it
critical race theory is not a new idea
despite what they tell you
in 1964 a third of senate democrats
voted against the civil rights act and
one of those who did was a man called
robert byrd
byrd was a strident supporter of equity
or who was called at the time
jim crow in 1944 at the height of the
second world war robert byrd wrote a
letter to theodore bilbo
a fellow democrat who represented
mississippi in the senate
byrd was upset that the roosevelt
administration was giving federal jobs
to people with the wrong skin color
robert byrd was the tammy duckworth of
his day quote
i shall never fight in the armed forces
with a negro by my side
bird wrote amazingly rather i should die
a thousand times and see old glory
trampled in the dirt never to rise again
than to see this beloved land of ours
become degraded by race mongrels a
throwback to the blackest specimen from
the wilds
end quote that's real robert byrd wrote
that
at the time he did write it bird was
working as a recruiter for the ku klux
klan which was very much the
yale university of the time the source
of so much poison in our society
two years later bird wrote to a
well-known critical race theorist called
joel baskin who was at the time serving
as the grand wizard of their beloved
organization
quote the clan is needed today as never
before robert byrd wrote and i am
anxious to see its rebirth here in west
virginia
it is necessary that the clan be
promoted immediately and in every state
in the union will you please inform me
as to the possibilities of rebuilding
the clan realm
of west virginia end quote that's real
once again
shortly after he wrote that letter
robert byrd abandoned his clan career it
never paid well
instead he decided to run for office as
a democrat
robert byrd served in the congress for
nearly 60 years
when byrd died during barack obama's
first term the entire leadership of the
democratic party came forward to slobber
over his memory including amazingly
barack obama himself
it is almost impossible to imagine the
united states senate without robert byrd
said hillary clinton byrd was not just
its longest-serving member he was its
heart
and soul for my first day in the senate
i sought out his guidance
hillary clinton said and of course she
did
while some simply bore witness to
history remarked an emotional nancy
pelosi
senator byrd shaped it and strove to
build a brighter future for its all
vice president joe biden always big on
memorials and funerals went on for
perhaps the longest
biden described robert byrd as quote a
very close friend of mine one of my
mentors
here's joe biden misquoting william
shakespeare as he celebrates his
klansmen mentor
when i learned of his death i was on an
errand
for president in cleveland
and i said you know to paraphrase the
poet
we shall not see his like again mr
leader
we're not going to look upon you like
again
i'm not going to ask god to bless you
because he already has and i know where
you are
oh but you're thinking that was a long
time ago and
biden probably doesn't even remember
that was way back in the summer of 2010
when people just didn't know any better
they thought the ku klux klan was some
kind of
harmless fraternal organization like the
elks or the rotary
right no they knew underneath it all
they never really disagreed with the
core idea
only the colors have changed there
exists in the darkest parts of human
nature the instinct to form a mob
and attack people for how they were born
fear of the other is what sociologists
call it they say it's a function of
evolutionary biology wherever it comes
from however you describe this
phenomenon
it is real and it is a grave threat to
america
this is an enormous complex and yes
diverse
society we have very little in common
with each other apart from the fact that
we are all
americans 350 million people live within
the borders of this country
most of us can't leave so we have to
live together
if you want americans to live peacefully
without hurting each other
you have to treat them as individuals
not as members of warring
tribes you have to guarantee that every
american has the same
the identical opportunity to work and
live and go to school
as well as the same the identical
judgment under the
law equality under the law you can't
just announce that americans of a
certain color can't have jobs
if you do that things will tend to fall
apart very quickly we fought a war over
this once by the way
seven hundred thousand people died and
it wasn't that long ago that all
americans
understood this or pretended they did
but then a new generation of robert
birds took control of the democratic
party and
dark and primitive forces have been
unleashed
you see them everywhere you hardly need
to be reminded of it but here's just one
example from yesterday
the nation magazine the flagship
publication of the american left
ran a piece with this title quote i am
not ready to re-enter white society
now this was written by a harvard law
graduate called ellie mistahl
here's the open quote i've said here and
elsewhere that one of the principal
benefits of the pandemic
is how i've been able to exclude racism
and whiteness generally from my
day-to-day life
over the past year i have of course
still had to interact with white people
on zoom
or watch them on television or worry
about whether they would succeed in
reelecting a white supremacist president
but white people aren't all in my face
all the time
i can more or less only deal with
whiteness when i want to
white people haven't improved i've just
been able to limit my exposure
to them end quote that's someone who
went to harvard law school that is not
normal
and it's not healthy it is open race
hate and it's the beginning of actual
destruction
as with senators hirono and duckworth no
one in power said a word about it so
naturally exhibitions like that
accelerate and they become more
dangerous
last week a corporate-owned website
called the root published a kind of
terror manifesto
written by a new york times contributor
called daemon young
the tracks begins like this quote
whiteness is a public health crisis
it shortens life expectancies it
pollutes air it constricts equilibrium
it devastates forests it melts ice caps
it sparks and funds wars
it flattens dialects it infests
consciousness
and it kills people so with that
established that
whiteness is the most dangerous force
in the world young writes this quote
white supremacy is
a virus that like other viruses will not
die
until there are no bodies left for it to
infect
which means the only way to stop it is
to locate it
isolate it extract it and kill it
end quote and kill it
you have to ask yourself where's this
going exactly
let's pull back now before we find out